i got to hear the back story on this
adam's is it garbage to have cousins
suing each other on judge judy
man
the fact that you actually follow
through with it
that's the real trashy part i'll see
your ass on channel four [ __ ]
judy gonna grieve me i'll tell you that
right now
steal my toaster oven [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he listed their names like we know them
yeah it's not a it's not a garbage sat
question
if i'm trashing brandon's trash
how are you going to get on judge duty
if brandon smokes the whole bag
who is brandon and who was the other
name amanda who those are two [ __ ]
royal garbage [ __ ] names
holy [ __ ] she's a stripper and he's been
in and out of rehab
a lot of brandon's at shady pines around
this time of year
sweating it out how much was it for
600
i got that on me
that's not going to cover the court fees
i know where do they shoot judge judy on
the east coast right
oh they
you sound like you've been honest oh my
god
they give you a sandwich too and a
little snickers bar it's all right
i was there for that one amanda had it
coming
you won
was he owed the money or he stiffed
amanda
cousins living together yeah
on paper that's always going to start
out fantastic
ends at judge duty
did they continue to live together after
that or no
no of course
they're not animals yeah hold on what'd
you say
who she's currently suing on judge joe
brown
she's got to make that six hundy back
what are you gonna do
you dumb fish they were my crackers
told you don't touch a diet coke wow man
do they talk
thanksgiving's got to be mad weird at
your place dude
god damn they definitely sit and watch
it together
you were pretty good on that you were
pretty good too
there's got is there a vhs of this
floating around somewhere
you've been searching
that's even trashy yeah
spending his days at the library like
give me season four yo my cousin's in a
movie man check it out
get her an imdb page
that's a home run of the question man
give a big round
sf came to play baby yikes
judge judy dude that's nuts
where's chaldo at
what's up
chaldo oh i'm sorry
he acts like i pronounced john wrong or
something
[Laughter]
it's actually celdo thank you
more champagne over here please thank
you put some seven up in it it'll be
fine
brother who are you here with man
all right very cool very vague i like it
with a female yeah
ciao doesn't like to get pegged down i
can tell
child has many relationships
chaldo's your kj i dig
it sounds like a shitty designer is that
a child though that's nice
knock off aldo shoes are they chaldos
ah it's beautiful when i want cheap
shoes i go to ciao
where'd you guys meet buddy
oh high school sweethearts
at one time
yo
don't [ __ ] play
yeah no [ __ ] he really killed the
romantic story on that at one point then
she [ __ ] my brother
[Laughter]
chow don't like that [ __ ]
his never crossed ciao
we could do this all night i like this
is all right man we found our wheelhouse
with childhood
[Laughter]
you're hired toby you better be
recording ah
you ever pretend to be asleep
that's [ __ ] not starting out good
dude
that sounds like a real childhood mood
you ever pretend to be asleep while
sitting in the handicapped seat on a bus
so you don't have to give it up
[ __ ] childhood
what a piece of [ __ ]
you're a real dirt bag dude
what i mean is there people walking by
with like canes and [ __ ]
yeah
they start tapping you're like
he's doing the real bad fake snore
oh dude
take the bus a lot do you child
yeah
i feel like that name don't match up to
the checking account you know what i
mean
seems more like a [ __ ] cash app kind
of guy
you ever scam handicapped people on the
bus
you're pushing old woman down in the
middle of the street
chowder then when they fall
you just got chow dude
[Applause]
ciao strikes again
the handicapped person's not even mad
geldo
that's just childhood you've just been
childhood
i love that show